13 white strawberry versus a three
dollar red strawberry let's see if
people can taste the difference this
tastes very familiar it's very flavorful
it's juicy but it's not giving like
expensive juice The Taste is very
familiar oh this one's immediately so
much better it's a little big storm this
is a strawberry flavored strawberry this
is so good okay that was really good a
little bit
flourish this does taste like a really
good strawberry
it kind of tastes like a normal
strawberry
smells more like a peach this one
doesn't have any flavor
definitely
this is way more delicious I think
oh I was wrong I definitely pay more for
this one really that's a scam this is
more expensive oh yeah I'm smart I feel
like this one was sweeter my right side
I had bad taste I guess the white ones
actually known as a pine variant
originated from South America the
average 13 a box I'm gonna die 13 bro
that is like arowana steroids